so is low-light shooting leaving you in
the dark if so this is the video for you
we're going to be gone through a couple
cool things for low-light shooting such
as how to prepare yourself for a
low-light shooting how to shoot the best
footage in the dark how to deal with a
bunch of crappy low light dark grainy
footage in case you've accidentally
already shot it and then also at the end
talk about some cool day for night tips
that's not necessarily about shooting
dark footage but it's how to make it
look dark so the first part is how to
intentionally shoot for low light
situations so there are two ways you can
influence the amount of light getting
into your camera one is with the
aperture which is how open your lenses
the second way is with your shutter
speed which is how long you're letting
light hit your sensor and/or film
what does ISO do then ISO seems to be
making my image brighter and darker well
what I saw is effectively doing is
shifting the gray point of your picture
imagine you have a levels filter and you
have a little middle gamma slider and
levels and as you move that around your
picture B seems to be getting brighter
and darker but your brightest point is
staying in same spot and your darkest
point is staying at the same spot that
is what ISO is doing so when you are in
a dark situation you can't see a lot and
you start cranking that ISO on your
camera it's not actually making any more
light hit your picture even though your
picture appears brighter when in a dark
situation use your ISO to get to a
picture that looks nice for you but
don't crank it until it's bright what
you need to do at the end of the day is
get more light into your shot if you can
shoot with a lower ISO which will make
your picture look darker and get more
light into the scene you will have a
cleaner image so what this all actually
means is that when you want to have a
dark scene you don't want to turn all
your lights off what you want to do is
lower your ISO so you're still getting a
clean image with no noise and then raise
your lights to compensate for that what
that does is it eliminates the noise and
it eliminates all the fuzz and grain and
compression errors you get with dark
footage Plus now you can see everything
and you have full control of your shot
that's right you're getting light into
your sensor they're using ISO to make it
look dark speaking of which this shot
right now we're actually shooting on a
super low ISO this is what it looks like
at a normal exposure
well we reasonably lit Wow see the thing
is is that the actual shot doesn't look
that nice but because we've lowered the
itis
so we're increasing the shadows and
increasing the darker areas and
essentially we're getting a darker
looking shot without compromising the
actual quality of the footage so more
light means less noise and more room and
post to work with your image so here are
some tips for you guys when you're
shooting a low-light situation first off
you're gentle gonna have a dark
foreground object against a dark
background and for that use an edge
light to separate your objects another
great thing you can do is put a light
somewhat near the camera this reflects
off the person's eyes it helps the
audience find the emotional center of
the frame or as we call it the eyes
that's called an eye light another cool
thing you can do to get the most out of
your light is to use a lower f-stop lens
we're using a 1.4 f-stop lens and what
that is doing is it allows an extra stop
of light into this shot but you have to
watch out because that stops this low
give you really shallow depth of field
so pulling focus becomes really
difficult also another thing you can do
to cut down on noise and grain and
low-light situations is use a higher
resolution camera so what that does is
basically as you go higher resolution
for your picture your pixels are
becoming smaller and smaller as part of
the actual image and since noise tends
to be on a pixel size basis when your
pixels are really tiny that makes your
grain very fine and very tiny which
looks a lot more pleasing than big
blotchy spots of noise yeah alright so
what happens if you forgot everything we
just told you in your shot is really
grainy and noisy well have no fear
because there are noise removal plugins
out there for your editing and or
special effects program of choice in our
case we use neat video which is
obviously one of the best noise removal
plugins we've ever seen okay some point
check out the shot now boom no more
noise how did that happen we use neat
video on it go there website to find out
more information so that about covers it
for the challenges you're going to get
when trying to shoot in low light
situations now what about when you're
trying to do day for night Eco shooting
day for night generally means applying a
filter to your footage but this does not
mean tinting everything blue and
darkening it instead what you want to do
is desaturate every color except for the
greens blues and purples in your shop
this actually is a more accurate
representation of what light coming from
the moon to the stars looks
another thing you can do if it's not
overcast and you have direct sunlight is
use a silk which will diffuse the
sunlight and make it soft and ambient on
the characters and one last thing that
we like to do and I've done this once on
our after Daisy piece is you go out
right as the Sun is setting and just as
the point when the Sun goes beyond the
horizon the sky's still kind of light
bluish darkish um and that way you can
actually get contrast from your subjects
against a slightly brighter sky it makes
a nice image it's not quite nighttime
but color correcting it to look like
night is real easy
all right said about wraps things up
guys if you have any questions on things
we didn't cover or want to see us cover
different things in the future go ahead
and leave a comment below
and honestly check out neat video it's
made by this one guy who's in like
Romania I think don't pirate it it's not
expensive we we've been using it for
years at this point I can't even
remember how long it's been out but it's
a lifesaver and we use it pretty much on
every single project we do yeah pretty
much this entire video is just check out
neat video it'll solve your problems I
promise this wasn't sponsored by neat
video it really wasn't I mean I mean
it's seven years of using it probably at
this point yeah crazy anyways guys
looking forward to hear what you think a
video see you on the Internet in the
future
nice run